so now that you know how to set the
viewport meta let's poke around in the
developer tools to see what we need to
do to fix this page now the biggest
problem here is that the page has a
fixed column width if I resize the
window you'll notice the column of text
doesn't actually change size just margin
position as we mouse around the elements
inside the devtools we can pretty
quickly find the first defending element
this page element here actually has a
width set on it let's disable that and
see what happens well it certainly
changed things but I don't think it
actually improved things very much let's
keep digging inside the content and see
what we can find this wrapper element
has a width of a hundred percent already
which is good it means that it's not
preventing us from resizing but this
content element does have a width set in
pixels let's disable that now is we
resize the page our content is fine but
the sidebar is appearing and
disappearing sure enough it has a width
set if we set its width as a percentage
also now we're resizing a little bit
better so now let's go back up to the
page and let's try giving it a whipped
but let's give it a width in viewport
units instead now our only remaining
problem seems to be that the header is
actually not resizing as we want it to
let's go take a look at the header image
again the image has a max width set but
not just a width so let's set its width
and now everything seems to be resizing
well now this isn't perfect but all that
I really wanted to get at was that as
you try to transition pages from fixed
layout to fluid layout the core things
to look for are fixed pixel sizes and
lack of percentage resize